what's with the jeans hi hi sans one
mommy who is home very sick right now
and we miss you and we hope you feel
better mommy jeans yes does he have like
a flu type thing going on there or
what's going on now I'll tell you what
my husband has he it's like he's on his
deathbed
really can't breathe he's just he can't
breathe and his little chest hurts
very dramatic bear very he got Sam sick
and he had Sam did a podcast yesterday
and Sam just had a little sniffles he's
like yeah Tom got me sick I'm fighting
it I fight it with my mind I believe
it's mind over matter
I fought diarrhea I have had explosive
diarrhea and cabs in like the Middle
East and you know what you can will it
away you think that's true I know it's
true I'm doing more diarrhea right you
can will away I'm telling you I have had
explosive diarrhea in cabs like in the
middle of like Mexico City traffic and I
have actively willed away the shit pains
and then it's hard it's not easy but if
you clinch and you pray and you clench
and you relax it's possible I would like
to see you have AIDS and try that just
wish it away count I can make higher by
thinking about it how have you been
right been we've gone a whole week I
haven't seen you yes what's going on
with you that's fine went to Santa
Barbara this weekend again it's at
velvet Joan's which is I love velvet
Jones I love the owner velvet Jones I
don't think it's the best place for a
naughty show but it's it's one of those
play it was one of those places where
like the front half was paying attention
and the other second half of it was like
a drunken mob at a frat house so you get
on stage after like kind of screen your
bits because you're just trying to
yeah called babysitting we were in Fort
Lauderdale
two weeks ago Tommy and I and the crowd
was like that word they're just chatty
they think they're at home in their
living room and you're like dude just
fucking pay attention yeah if you paid
money like they paid money to be a mad
90 like it was like 14 bucks or someone
yeah I know Vegas is like that Vegas is
a weird crowd - it's always you never
know what the fuck you're gonna get but
listen guy listeners I know you guys
have been thinking about this all week
and now breaking news Cristina's Dental
wha shiz major story when I left here
last week I had to leave in a hurry to
make it to my appointment and let me
tell you what happened I got in the
chair I thought I was just gonna get my
crown put on turns out I needed a root
canal are you fucking serious
Wow let me tell you what the best part
of a root canal is not only spending
$1,300 that's the there's something
better that's the fun part
and then the Crown's like an additional
the fun part is getting to watch the
entire procedure and it was elective
lens light above my head you know and
the ten shots that go into your fucking
jaw it's just the good news is
painkillers right I don't know if I've
ever had a I've had almost every single
thing possible done to my mouth I don't
think I've ever had a root canal
recognize what where they take the roots
and they redirect them through your gum
you know it's um you know taste your
food twice here Bryan skleros calzone
joke we like this goes on so good when
you eat it you're gonna want to sell
your asshole shut so that you could keep
it in your body longer
laughs okay no so we're counting just
they take out the nerves so they they
dig into your dad drill into my tooth
and then they pull out the roots they
clean out the the pulp or infection and
then they put in stumps or something gay
you know I don't know but the guy that
just came out of nowhere though they
were like oh by the way you need a root
canal even though you were here last
week we're just trying to make an extra
buck no I think what is the the tooth
was so fucking old and they the filling
was so large that it was gone that he
was it was about to happen he was hoping
it wouldn't happen but it got infected
so that's it so now I'm you know in the
hole couple grand for one goddamn tooth
one motherfucking tooth we shouldn't
just pull it I got an update to last
night I had a headache yeah and I went
to go get my tie and all and Christina
had knocked my tie on all to the floor
of the bathroom last time she was here
but I did find a vicodin when I got my
dental implants and I took a vicodin
that was that was good it was nice and
I'm not a huge fan of vikon and when I
have to take it every day because then I
start feeling like a fucking retard and
I start becoming dull man yeah but once
in a while not too bad I spilled over
and then here's the best part is that I
fell all over your bathroom floor right
and I started to pick them up so I was
like oh the cats are gonna eat these and
died right and then I was like wow this
floor are so goddamn filthy
but these back in the container Brian
will die no oh you got him thank you
very much that was very unnecessary the
note iron always wave past it's
expiration date anyway and I'm
respectful and I respect other people's
property well thank you that's how my
mama raised me mama right you know my
bathroom is really filthy uns
you know and I tried to get a maid now
and people like people like protect
their maids I've found like they have a
good maid and they don't give you your
number or they say they're busy other
way past though they have too much on
their schedule or now yeah we're trying
to find one and we've been asking comics
yeah why it's because I don't know
telling secrets of what the other comics
have I guess like oh you should see
Pablos well you know I don't know
speaking of Mexican old ladies we have I
didn't know segue to you
you guys we have in in mom's house today
one of my favorite favorite human beings
and on paper this girl and I should not
be friends because well we'll get into
that later yeah she is so goddamn funny
you've seen her on Reno 911
you have seen her in Activia commercial
Jamie Lee Curtis you can see her every
week at the Comedy Store please welcome
the fabulous Sarah Tiana
you are what are you watching on your oh
the Braves game is tied and it does went
into extra innings I'm watching feels
like she's a gender trader yes it feels
like we should not be friends because as
you know I have a low thing of team
sports
or any physical activity mm-hmm well you
know you might low that if you're not
good at it you don't have rhythm or
coordination we've been for a walk
around the circle the other day and she
tripped twice in a circle
there was no Hill reservoir and I wore
my sports bra just in case a trot came
somehow you might you had to pick up
speed like maybe run from some sort of
close my eyes and think of my country
I'm so fucking lazy I'm so you're here I
thank you for so many years we almost
weren't friends I know I know it's a
funny story because I knew Christina for
so long yeah and we always got along so
well and then I knew your husband Tom
for just as long I never knew but they
were together because each one of them
thought the other one hated me and they
would never bring up the other person in
our conversation yeah and it was like
three years of knowing you that I did it
when I finally she was she came she told
me this story she's like I came home and
I think it was after we did orange
county's funniest me or California smell
which we always won but we gave the
title away to other people for years and
she said she came home and was like man
I just love Sarah tea on it he's like
wait I like well kiss for years he
thought it was forbidden to bring up
your news
because there are people that I hate and
I'm very you know I thought you just he
thought that I hated her so her name was
never to be spoken it was like the
Voldemort it was the reason I think is
one day came home yeah and know how it
started and then I eventually out at
myself I was like they were together in
like
funny Sarah was at like the Ice House
once or she was there like the week
before and I was just like looking at
the flier talking to the sound guy the
deejay guy and I'm like oh man I love
Sarah Tiana and and and he goes no I
love her and like he was like he was
like obsessed with her and this guy was
like no man this is that's my girl and
like he was like I'm like haha oh you're
being serious like he was really upset
so you have a deejay fucking in love
with you you know Sarah Tiana and I are
going to the Middle East pretty soon yes
entertainer oh wait no we're not doing
stand-up we're going over there it is
the best soldier ever you take bigger
dumps than most
tell me about Jamie Lee Curtis oh and
let me get this straight now I don't
know if you've seen these commercials
but Sarah Tiana in addition to being on
other wonderful television programs is
also in the Activia I was not running
anymore tell me a little bit about Jamie
Lee Curtis and about her bowels because
it seems to me that she would have the
most regular bowels in the industry if
she does she buys it herself actually
she says they don't give it to her she
buys it she used to buy her own actually
what she doesn't have to but she chooses
to but she just first of all can I tell
you that that stuff works it does work I
actually have a bit about it works
because I actually accidentally bought
Activia I had no idea that there was a
blessing in the sky Activia
I got in know what it was no I know it
trust me I did a lot of research after I
bought a TV oh by mistake what happened
they had they had a TV for sale like
they had like it was super fucking cheap
and so I bought a shitload of it because
they're so small and like they're like
like little baby ones like what's this
big who cares it's so cheap so I bought
a shitload of it and then I ate it for
like a week like a lot of it and I
started fucking going crazy shitting and
so like I had no idea and then I looked
at it I was like oh this is helping me
poop that's disgusting
this was like a year ago I had no idea
that that even exists it's a covert you
know you never it's just like to help
like the whole lines in the commercial
like you know to help you live a healthy
lifestyle
yeah and it's like me and the guy and
the commercial Matt knows he's a comic
at the comedy story played husband and
wife in this commercial and and we
they're like do you guys want to spit it
out you know when your truck cuz at the
end you have to eat it oh you do like
you know 40 takes yeah oh and you know
the client is there
it's feel good inside yeah that's when
you take a shit you feel good you're
clean I mean and well I didn't I mean I
knew that first of all is not bad but
once you find out what it is you're kind
of like creeped out a little it's like
it's like knowing that there's a pubic
hair somewhere at all and I was actually
like really excited it like wow you know
like I well I was actually really
excited when I it felt like it worked
because like you don't want to spit it
out because the client is there all that
you know like yeah I'm like I don't you
know after like an hour you're like like
it was the last take of the day and I'm
driving home like why would an amazing
day like I get to meet Jamie Lee Curtis
who is like by far the coolest lady ever
and and she's married to Christopher
Guest so you know that she's like got
like an amazing sense of humor already
yeah and then I'm like driving home and
I get to like downtown LA and I was like
oh my god I've got to pull over you know
what good news you can shit in the
street but it works that and it made me
very proud too you know that's full
circle now they do the same thing with
birth control pills it's always under
the ruse of you know right you let your
period and nobody mentions fucking it's
never like girls now you can just fuck
you can fuck all day and that's really
it's always as veiled cool because
that's not what we do as women we're
like yes
we do fuck all day guys would be like
where we'll be there okay why would we
ever promote that did guys would be
trying to jump through the television
they'd be like pausing it seeing where
it was shot like all of a sudden men
would become detective wait I know that
corner fucking did that with Megan Fox
there was a TMZ article or thing where
she's like Megan Fox out having Thai
food in Burbank I'm like wait wait what
because I said her favorite Thai food
place and Burbank and I'm like what the
fuck so i zoomed in on photoshop it took
like the still and veloute most like
trying to look at the sign of the the
menu and i found it and it's like oh my
god it's all right across the street and
so I go there and I'm like so there's
Megan Fox come here yes so now I go to
this Thai place once a week just just in
case I usually sneeze when I walk out
the door almost immediately at second
sip mam gotta go clear that out no TV
and unit no I do you guys because you
sound like the two most amazing what
you're not regular once I'm a good three
sir I usually do three yeah you said
three I mean one of them's kind of
bullshit no that's cuz I eat so much
vegetables they're solid nice just goes
right through I don't want to about it
floating sorry that when it flows it's
got a flow yes and it's got to be like a
banana I saw what she says like a light
brown banana I believe you know light
brown means too many carbohydrates
yeah but what if it's like the
soft-serve ice cream boy let's do all
right let's you know here let's change
the subject because I I find this fat
another reason I shouldn't be friends of
Sarah T on paper is that she is from
Georgia and I don't know also if you
know this but guess who else is from
Georgia wait one of my favorite movie
stars of all time Billy Robert no no she
is from there Madea oh I love first of
all I love certain types of movies you
know this any movie where animals talk
ah love those any movie with a baby and
then any movie where black people rise
above remember Shirley Q liquor did you
ever listen to Shirley Q liquor no
that's who Medea sounds like to me I
swear Tyler Perry stole that boys not
stole it but like how dare you say stole
but I would say like how dare you if you
never heard Shirley Q liquor it's just
white kid he's this white kid from like
the Midwest and I used to call in to
radio shows all the time and he sounds
like okay tell your mom and him I love
him
and hilarious like there's tons of like
um before I mean it was always on
Napster but like it's not on i.t I hate
to break it to you but a lot of large
black woman sound like Madea this little
white kid in it was so funny I had this
new word that I want to use well I just
realize you guys spelled my name wrong
eonni
oh my god says an island darius yeah not
tea on me maybe you know I saw I saw
Tyler on Oprah and he it's based on his
aunt who like saved him when he was
being a bitch Wow
it was he's got a really bad like horse
yeah but you know it's a good place to
make movies and do your own thing I just
uh I mean I want to be sometimes I just
want to be a black woman cuz I want to
say things like escalator yeah oh yeah
I'm gonna write no yeah elevator I'm
gonna take that this escalator is in
Atlanta it was the first time I was
there with you we went in December
what's really surprising is when you do
see like a lot of people yeah at one
place and they're just living normal Oh
Atlanta is like black Canada right like
black Canada is like where black people
buy to each other
buy from each other sell to each other
and you know why people just don't get
in and it's pretty amazing like when I
moved to Los Angeles I was like we're
all black right this is so weird and
like everything in la is so segregated
like there's Koreatown in Chinatown and
Little Ethiopia and Armenia Ville or
whatever and so it's like it was so
bizarre for me to come here and be like
wow this is like segregation for this
for years and you come here and you're
seeing it right I think out loud it is
very bizarre for me what I'm saying that
in Atlanta it seemed like oh like this
is normal like this feels more normal to
me than the way we do shit ya know it's
it's well I think Atlanta is also very
progressive town as opposed to like you
know maybe another it also has the best
Real Housewives I think it's the only
one I like yeah tell you you know Sarah
mm-hmm you love the chick-fil-a yes I
know this about you uh-huh did you ever
did you like Kentucky Fried Chicken I
mean we likes Kentucky Fried Chicken but
it wasn't the same I mean for me it was
always like there's too much grease like
batter on
- much better oh yeah I mean we I mean
first of all listen we did not have a
sit-down restaurant in my hometown till
I was 18
okay did you so yeah she just yeah we
did not on this plate and played with a
hose growing we at Pizza Hut kind of had
like and like Waffle House they have
like waitresses but we got a Cracker
Barrel when I was 18 and it was like
nobody could not get in just so busy but
my parents didn't go to church so you
could always get in Sunday morning so it
was like we were like the only people it
was like a ghost town you either
Southern Baptist or you were getting
ready to move my dad your choice oh but
we always had I mean it was great
growing up I mean because we had we were
like the only family in town really that
had an in-ground pool in ground pool so
all the pool parties were always at my
house every year like the end of the
year school party it was always at my
house and it's so much fun like but then
there was always that one kid that like
was like a little too good on the diving
board it's a man's turn again you know
one and a half Pike what's this Colonel
say oh it's so great Colonel Sanders at
some point he was trying to do those
commercials he used to do them himself
and then he got senile I don't know how
he was how he had time cuz he didn't
thank your Colonel in the fighting
overseas he also did audio and there's
this audio clip we found of him fucking
up the the commercial spot towards like
the end of it's really funny he's like
see now he's senile any camera
another reason why I do not know how
even I think that's that I'm just
thinking of the poor Colonel sitting
there shaking trying to get out his
lines that he's been saying for so many
years he's holding on to I just wanted
to say I always like Popeyes can I just
say it I feel like I need a vent
somewhere they used to have like a
really racist sign it was like a like a
blackface character oh wow there is some
rumor about Church's Chicken you guys
you guys remember sisters chicken new I
think it was only you know see I live
for it in Columbus Ohio where is it
sister sister chicken no no no that's a
good show Sister Sister I live in
Columbus Ohio which is like one of the
test market capitals of the world so
seriously it's so like
this is Wendy's headquarters
well it's cuz the most average boring
but that's like we're Wendy's is from
where white castle's from said they
would like put out like these weird
things once in a while it was just a
test to see how it happens one of the
things I think was sisters chicken which
was owned by Wendy's but was their
version of Kentucky Fried Chicken so it
was fucking amazing now but what what
and all that stuff it was really
delicious and then there was this place
called Dena toes and then when these are
McDonald's body and it used to be Dena
knows pizza used to be this place in
Columbus Ohio that everyone loved like a
hometown pizza place and then I think it
was Windies maybe I don't know one of
the two bought it it was like oh great
there goes our pizza place and they
tried to franchise it out but it didn't
work so they sold it back oh great that
was a really interesting
I know I was like halfway through and
like why am I going into this I was
hungry but they would bring out burgers
that were like disgusting because they
were just testing to see what was good
like guacamole barbecue for you guys you
guys also dictate what television shows
get picked up right oh no that's here we
had groups of 12 year old no no no
that's the devil decide Oh Satan sorry
Satan decide and then he'll of his
minions put it out can I just say trying
Roseanne Barr released a great article
today in the New York Post about the
genesis of her sitcom
and you know a bunch of other shit well
I got to tell you these fucking sitcoms
where they really really suck my asshole
and I don't there's very few scripted
shows I can laugh at
I think eastbound and down is a great
show yeah I like Nurse Jackie well I
love these mountain uncle's based on
John Rocker who's one of my favorite
Hannah
of all time probably like they calling
the most racist guy ever but he's like
the most invigorating guy yeah he got
kicked out of the league because he made
all these racist remarks in New York on
the train or in like an interview either
we can interview and like can I tell you
something I don't even mind I was I
don't mind
sexism or racism as long as it's out in
the open
if someone's just like I hate women
they're not funny I'm like right we're
not gonna be friends yeah
and same with racist people like if you
don't like this or that just fucking say
it so that I don't have to be friends
with you and then it's done you know
that's how its fight like I was always
like in the South you know when
someone's a racist because they're like
burning across you know like what
they're wearing some sort of you know
waving a flag but like then he'll go
I'll go up north to like Boston or fully
and then it's just understood and that's
when it creeps me out you know it's like
yesterday black people don't come in
here and I'm like what very bizarre I
mean I always say that like the most
redneck part of my family's in Michigan
and cuz my dad's from Monroe and like I
don't even want my parents to go visit
their ex I'm afraid that they're gonna
be like we should buy a van with
curtains and my uncle J are so I always
say like he no he would never say that
n-word because he prefers to shout it
usually off a houseboat in the middle of
Lake Erie but the way it sounds when it
comes off the water is really beautiful
but that it's very you're very right
like when people are secretive about it
or when they don't know yeah yeah and
that's also that's like very much of a
problem
and this is why Christina and I are
friends because we get very riled up
about like injustice and I think I think
injustice is the thing that makes me
more angry than anything well can I tell
you it gets me real fired up no here's
why blow job I love giving them I can't
stop I don't feel like that we could
ever give enough of them
especially for parts airplane tickets
anything here's why I like sateen
because I am Eurotrash my family is from
Hungary we are working-class people
my dad owns a forklift company we're not
fancy people and I feel a kinship to the
American southern person I feel because
I'm white trash does your white trash
which trash is better I think it's a
classic you know it's well I think it's
also that you know I think you and I are
a little bit more free spirits and you
know free thinkers especially when
you're raised in a culture that was like
no this is the way we treat women this
is the way things happen and I think
because my parents were not from the
south my parents are from dads from
Michigan my mom's from California so I
grew up in the south looking at things
in a completely different way and that's
probably how you felt being here so all
of a sudden you're thinking for yourself
from this from a young age point so then
I think the reason why I get to get
along with Sara so much is her Kathy and
Dennis yeah and if you look at the TV
tech he actually was in the Catman
Daniel video was hard hard shooting that
day because techie the whole time Tech
is just scraping her up like all the
girls just had wounds you know it was
funny when they showed this at the Noddy
so no one believed that that was a real
website I know it is a real my mom makes
every single one of those
bandanas yeah I think it's great because
I actually collect cat hats and target
cells
so Sara if you don't know Sara town
actually her mother makes these cat
bandanas they see yeah I sell them at my
show yes and then we sell them online
but like it started as a joke like my
basically it was like sibling rivalry
like I would told my sister my mom would
make these bandanas for my sisters black
labrador I was like you don't let me
nevermind with my cat and then see my
mom started making little ones for my
cat as a joke and then my friend started
wanting to buy them and then you know
they're great have you ever thought
about selling them at Target because
target cells cat hats you might just be
able to get a meeting with somebody at
Target nearby a shit looks even better
probably the best place but I think what
we're gonna do is take them to groomers
first of all that doesn't match no that
was her fall collection that website
scab bandana by the way and they're
great then they have a bunch of
different cat bent bandanas like candy
corn I even saw the Beatles on there we
also have this elastic ones for when if
they'd in case I don't wear a collar I
can be like assess you naked kitty it's
like stretchy jeans for fat chicks
it's it's so fucking cute too I've ever
bought pregnancy pants before just
because they're super comfortable
because I almost did the other day I was
like wow these shoes look so comfortable
and stretchy jean pants have you seen
those that look like they're they look
exactly like jeans they have pockets
look that look like pockets on jeans and
they look exactly jeans but they're
pajamas like they're made out of like
cotton but they're stretchy and you
could wear them out and the it looks
like you're wearing jeans but then you
touch them and you're like oh this is
just
you haven't given don't say anymore
because I don't know I don't know if
there was ever a time where I was like
yeah
Christina gives a shit about what she
was like you know on the prowl say there
there there genes but pajama jeans and
you know what I I was sitting there
watching this and I'm thinking you know
what that's actually pretty cool if it's
like 14 to 19 dollars I could see that
being really good but it's like 50 bucks
I mean I guess they're just like sweat
pants that look like jeans that's the
point yeah and you can like because
right now I'm wearing regular jeans
that's why I gotta pull your underwear
up to like kind of be like a girl lately
I've been buying the most gayest under
where I can find possible like I don't
know is bored with underwear so I've
been buying like Captain America
underwear and got Star Wars underwear
has like Darth Vader right where the
crotch is going here no they're for us
but Walmart has everything you could
she's checking the game what are you
gonna do when we're in the Middle East
and you can't watch your dumb I'm gonna
be I'm bringing this with me okay so
Sarah Tiana Jody Miller
yeah Tom Foss yo like Tom he's like this
old redneck from West Virginia he's
supposed to be our tour manager but now
he's gonna host the show and well okay I
mean this will be my seventh military
tour so it's like have you done this
route the Middle East one that we're
doing I haven't done Afghanistan I went
to Iraq in 2005 and I was in Iraq when
Saddam was still alive that's fuckin
yeah I mean it was like right
after Fallujah happened and I can
remember going into Abu curry like okay
so like this one time we were and I when
we were in Baghdad you can't fly
whenever there's a sandstorm because we
flying Black Hawk helicopters all the
time and they fly in twos because they
look out for each other but whenever
because they fly so low to the ground a
sandstorm is really dangerous because
you can't see the ground you can't see
what's shooting at least you can't fly
and so we finally get to Baghdad after
we've been trapped in a sandstorm in
this place called Diwaniyah which was
this multinational forces Polish camp
the Marines had bought it from like the
British troops and the Australia was
amazing but so we get to Baghdad and we
go to do this show somewhere in the
greens I don't remember the exact place
but like we go to leave and then go well
we can't fly because there's a sandstorm
and we had just like finally gotten into
like an like we were staying in Saddam's
a hunting lodge so we were like so
excited to just like stay in like a nice
place and like for the first time I
don't rip and then they're like well
we're gonna put you up at the hospital
you guys can sleep in the hospital and
we were like okay you know whatever so
we're like kind of saying about everyone
and packing up and then they go hey we
have a we're gonna we have a last second
flight that we're gonna let you guys
jump on that we've okay because we have
to drop some guys off at Abu Caribe and
we were like I'm sorry what yeah so we
get out to the tarmac and there's these
three guys on the tarmac on their knees
with hoods over their head and glow
sticks around their neck in case they
ran oh my god their hands are tied
behind their back and like they pick him
up and like throw them onto the one
chopper and we get on the other women
Abu Ghraib is that Club Med that they
just oh yeah it's so nice no no I swear
yeah yeah yeah there's like rappelling
and they have a rock wall inside is it
rock wall but people throw rocks at you
they ended up dropping us off first but
yeah we did have to shuttle with them
which ones very incredibly did you live
did you lift up the hood well you know
no because you're not supposed to look
under the veil no but you know what it's
just like I remember Abu Ghraib had just
happened like a few mean that was like
Fallujah Abu Ghraib all that stuff was
happening right around the same time and
like we would we were at this one base
where like you'd walk into like this
office that they had and there'd be like
a hook and the ceiling that had flypaper
on it and you're like why do you have a
what and like it you felt creepy as soon
as you walked in and then you look up
and you see flypaper and you're like
maybe it's the Flies and they go oh no
this used to be a torture chamber
Oh like this is where they are having
their offices right and so but you could
tell when you walked in and there was
something creepy about the room because
Saddam would have these parties and you
had to come to the party or you get
killed and if ya you know put a bounty
out on you and then like he'd throw this
party and and everybody move everybody
into the next room and if there was a
chandelier it was a party if there was a
hook someone was getting made an example
of so he would have these party you know
so like no one ever asked him over I
mean even like when we were in Baghdad
there's a Z Lake which goes around the
whole compound that he had there and the
Alpha Palace is in Baghdad and that's
the palace that he built when he said
that his after the first Gulf War when
he said he didn't have any money to feed
his people and he builds this like
billion-dollar mosaic you know castle
basically and the lake is full of carp
that they probably weigh like 50 pounds
each and that's all these fish in this
lake and the troops would go out there
and they would catch the fish but none
of the locals would eat the fish because
even though Saddam was like basically
had captured him it still wouldn't eat
it because Saddam had told them that
they were magic fish and the fish would
tell him if they were evil fuck them
over so bad in their minds that they
were so in fear of him and the power and
the control that he had over those
people was
I mean you have to that's crazy it's
it's so true like what you can't what
happens when you get power like a true
person is revealed once they get power
right and so he was a really great
leader at the beginning you know he
brought books and computers and he
started letting women drive he let women
vote you know I mean like you did all
these amazing things when he first
started and then he just decided well I
never want to leave office you know it
just got crazy okay yeah you do have to
wonder what kind of person wants to be
in charge I always wonder like if
someone were like Rossini would you like
to be president I'd really go fuck
yourself no never
yeah I would never assume you have to be
an egomaniacal to some extent lunatic to
want to have that much I'm not saying
Obama is a sociopath but I'm sure there
were people before you you feel like
that people like do more when they're
after their president I think you have
more power to get things done after your
president right when the pressure is not
on to like but you can also start
focusing on things that you specifically
care about as opposed to things that the
whole country cares about yeah yeah I
guess so man so I mean in that respect I
think it would be great but I mean I I
think that I mean you and I have talked
about this Villa like I feel like the
order of Last Comic Standing is exactly
the same order of like what America is
ready for yeah because it's a complete
slice of Lights like if you look at what
America like the first person who won
that fan means hey we're sorry about
Vietnam we still feel bad the next is
like a white guy join everyone yes and
then a black guy and then a paraplegic
guy yeah no then a southern guy then a
paraplegic knock this out of my head a
woman after after carefully and then a
Mexican guy and then I swear if they had
it this year then it would be an Arab
guy so wait a minute are we higher on
the totem pole than Mexicans yes usually
yes maybe I've done this Middle East
should just once a couple of years back
and you go to Saudi and the first thing
they do is they throw that stupid a bi
on you and
they wrap you up so that nobody cursed
about it's not stupid now whatever
fuckin Snuggie either I have to tell you
at first I was averse to wearing it and
then I wore it and I was like this is
awesome for the first time ever I am
invisible and it actually was like
alright so I can't vote I can't own
property I can't read in this country
but I can eat everything I want it's a
very it's a different obviously society
and I don't know I don't know the
bride's know that it's oppressive to
wear that stuff do you think they it's
so ingrained or they're like I think
it's also just it's just cool you know
isn't it no no I mean cooling like it's
very fuck not in black the black is
actually I'm sorry the women have to
wear black to cover their nasty bits so
men the sunlight can't penetrate through
that's why it's black the men actually
the white the white do you think the
women see it as oppressive to wear that
do you think that they're I think some
of them do green I mean I think I think
it's so true that like the way you know
we are all born with either we're going
left or we're going right not
politically but I mean like you either
go the way that your parents went or you
go the opposite way like there's really
great series of books out called
princess and it's all about the Saudi
princess princess Sultana and it's about
her life growing up and the royal family
and it's amazing series of books because
it's so she actually makes the man that
she you know the guy that she ends up
marrying he only marries her and they
kind of like proactively try to get more
rights for women out there and then she
has two daughters and one daughter
follows in her footsteps and the other
daughter becomes extremely religious and
refuses to talk to her mother and like
all this stuff you know so it's like I
think that women out there yeah I mean
I'm sure a lot of them like to talk to
them yeah I mean if I was wearing one of
those I would probably just carry some
like a knife stab people when they
weren't looking and you're like who did
it yeah I don't know it's a whodunit
yeah well cuz I did when I was in
Bahrain
we got to tour a mosque and this woman
was our tour guide and for two days I
knew her and I never saw her face she
had the full it's called a niqab right
the niqab is the full up to the eye oh
yeah and hands covered to cover up those
nasty ten little vaginas and and I
didn't see her face it was a weirdest
thing to know somebody and have her tell
you like intimate details of her life
and you just you never even knew that's
kind of refreshing to where you judge
someone based on their personality only
but the problem is they never take that
off you know it's like it's not like
some sort of test in like like America
we use that as some sort of like dating
game you know like dating in the dark
that's basically what that is but like
it just always dark I think we have our
next game show it's called dating in the
dark and we all wear burqas and now get
ready for today's Saddam Hussein chooses
his fifth wife and you get to be well
you know my ex-boyfriend is there so I
feel very you got the demon inside of
you what did your house smell like sand
he's actually very he's a very handsome
fellow I I ran into him I love this
music and I was actually taken with his
he had a sorcery about him why is the
dark hair and green eyes so that's
always Mormon you know yeah he's Arab
Mormon tortured you and say the fish was
gonna tell I think he really brought out
that part of me that really asked
questions because I didn't like how much
smarter he was than me so he made me
want to be
want to be you're very competitive with
everything yes it made me just like
really read up a lot and like and it
made me way more of an independent I
think I was now I mean like I I
definitely consider myself that like
just the idea of like someone telling me
how I should vote just because I'm in
your club is so annoying to me like I
definitely lean you know one way or the
other but I definitely but I'm like I
refuse to say like yes I'm voting
Democrat yes I'm voting Republican
because I feel like that is like the
most an American thing ever
like it's just like especially when you
grow up in the south when it's supposed
to be everything is based on religion
and it's like but I was given this mine
to make my own decisions and you're
saying that because you know I tend to
lean this way I should be in your club
and constantly vote with you and like
the club's change to the Republican plan
doesn't look at all like it did whatever
20 years ago nothing looks the same you
know and Erin's parents sit on the my
ex-boyfriends parents sit on the
Democratic National Committee so and you
know stuff in his house is from you know
yes or Arafat and Bill Clinton you know
like they have stuff oh I guess I know
where you guys stand and and it's
definitely like I definitely agreed with
them on a lot of things but instead it
made me more challenging as a person to
be like do I really feel like this or do
I just feel outnumbered right and so I
definitely started reflecting a lot more
it made me reflect a lot more on like
Who I am and what I want to be when
you're like why don't I feel this way
like why don't I accept this that and
the other that's a process mm-hmm
because you have your own mind I mean
people can make a very convincing
argument I think but you know that can
only take you so far I mean what does
that mean that like if the next guy Dave
is a Republican all of a sudden I'm
going to I wish I want you to vote for
Sarah Palin no I I can't wait to vote
for her she know
that was that was the most incredible
moment I've ever seen in politics when
Hillary didn't get the nomination and
the McCain was like I'll get all them
women kids just by kicking this lady and
we were all like it was one of my
proudest moments are you fucking serious
yeah and I just thought it was so
brilliant I went to Sara's a 21st
birthday recently and I actually held
her hair yeah I uh she sat down next to
me on the couch and I remember looking
over at you going oh okay
next thing I know you start doing the
spitting on the ground I'm like oh fuck
yes sorry there was like somebody's food
on the table in front of me and I just
like threw the food on the ground grab
like this little plate and I just hold
it underneath there and the next thing I
know you're being whisked away and I
didn't see it for the rest of the night
well can I tell you what a shitty friend
I am is that I have such a phobia of
vomiting that I knew Sarah was like on
the verge of getting sick and I ran away
you know what was so funny about that
party well first of all I was a great
party but I I woke up the next morning
first of all with no recollection of
what happened and I had on pajamas and
my Braves blanket was on me and all
there was a puke bucket next to me and
then all my presents were laid up it was
like Christmas and New Year's all at the
same time but then like from what I can
gather like I had three groups of people
there it was like all my friends who are
comics all my friends who would do
sketch comedy and then a bunch of people
that I've worked with over the years and
hotels and none of these three groups
trusted each other
nobody knew each other
so it's like hey what are you doing with
her are you taking her I remember some
guy came up to me never seen before he's
like yo have you seen Sarah's phone and
I'm like no her but wait
the black bear you haven't seen it and
like no like you stole but I think it
was because I was sitting next to Sarah
everyone thought I had taken her phone
it was a group of comics to everybody
who wrapped it into applause that I have
they might be comics and they're
definitely asshole it's because they all
took pictures of me but none of them put
them out incredibly crazy that's because
that's because we know it's truly funny
and that which is really funny between
that's true sacred I literally I feel
like I I grew up with the sister and I
wound up with like eight hundred
brothers that's kind of how stand-up
comedy feels yeah I've had a lot of fun
fun you know we you told me you think of
stories and I'm like life is a big
comedy story right you can't be normal
and be a comic you have to be in therapy
Sarah also has a hilarious CD that she
put on you did this yourself right on
iTunes yeah you pretty much did this all
yourself it could be found on iTunes
just search for Sarah Tiana and that's
TI a and a don't do the email like me
but Sarah Tiana I a second tatianna
so what's your your url so people can
find you
Sarah Tiana comm terminates Tiana with
the Tiana and she you do have a
hilarious sketch comedy that you do a
lie and I I fucking love your sketch
when I I didn't know you did it and I
saw you on the naughty show doing a
character and I just was fucking
laughing my ass off your hilarity have
you ever tried to do like the Saturday
Night Live's or anything like that cuz
it seems like Sarah Night Live would be
the perfect fit for you
thank you that's so sweet I mean I I've
been asked to audition a couple times
but I just haven't had the guts to do it
and and I think I probably will
eventually I think I've always just I
don't know I like to have a little bit
more freedom with what I do but I did
start a sketch comedy company six years
ago called the straitjacket Society and
we just got our own theater and
Hollywood so there's a link to it on my
website but like the Straight Edge
Society we basically do slice-of-life
comedy and like we have five different
shows that go up every week so there's
about 50 people recurring in the company
every season and then we probably put
about 250 300 people through the program
and we just bought our own theatre so
it's very exciting
that's 5150 that's the show address 5150
and don't forget about cat bandana know
if you have a cat you have to check this
out it's a perfect gift for like your
mom or your friends and stuff it's
hilarious and it makes your cat look
fucking awesome Scott's down Oh totally
different yeah there's the street and
then yes I direct a show every Saturday
at the straitjacket Society obviously
not this weekend but I'm also Kristina
and I both work at the Palms in Vegas
that's right I just did last week once a
month basically and then and then I'm
going overseas we're going together
you AE so it should be very exciting I'm
gonna wear my burka and my band about
you I'm tonight I'm at some club but
it's easy they're down at the Comedy
Store tonight I'm gonna be going crazy
this week with comedy though because my
girlfriend's gonna be out of town so I'm
just gonna have to relive it's funny
when I did I just easy row comedy like I
just don't have any desire to go out so
I'm just gonna make up for it from the
audience you get from another person
yeah it's actually probably healthy and
nothing it's hard being miserable when
you're happy that's the truth you know
what it's hard to be funny when you're
happy yeah which thankfully only happens
for me in windows of happiness so I can
so much up I'm gonna be at the Kansas
City improv this week if you guys are in
Kansas City please comment please let me
know if you heard us on the podcast cuz
I love meeting people that actually
listen to us yeah let me know - I'm
going into Phoenix early - what's the
Braves play such a gender traitor what
you seem very competitive I wonder in
bed if she's competitive like I'm gonna
come first that would be awesome again
my favorite TV shows are like survivor
Amazing Race which I watch they make me
I thought I was about white people but
it's not that's still a really good show
really good all right back and you can
tell us all about your competitive
streak next time okay and thank you guys
for listening to your mom's house we'll
see you next week see you guys